[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAIGE BAILEY: I'm Paige
Bailey, a TensorFlow developer
advocate.
And I'm here today with
Carla Bromberg, who's
going to tell us all about
our AI for social good efforts
at Google.
So tell us a little bit
more about it, Carla.
CARLA BROMBERG: Thanks, Paige.
So for AI for social
good, we have--
we aim to accelerate the
application of machine learning
to the world's
biggest humanitarian
and environmental issues.
So today I'm going to
tell you about some
of the core research
and engineering work
we're doing at Google,
more specifically,
the flood forecasting
initiative.
PAIGE BAILEY: Excellent.
So is this the flood
forecasting initiative here?
CARLA BROMBERG: Yes.
So this is our demo.
And so what this shows you
is how we're using machine
learning to help
forecast and predict,
with better accuracy,
where floods are.
So that way, we
can tell users when
they're affected by floods.
So earlier today
in the keynote, we
announced that we're
rolling this out
across a big portion of India.
And I'm going to
actually show you
the simulation that we have
for the demo here today.
So this simulation is over
the course of 48 hours.
So if you look, you can
see the water filling in.
So this is without
using machine learning.
You can see that the
accuracy is not very high.
And you can see,
also, that there's
a lot of regions that are
predicted to have floods.
Now with Google's flood
forecasting effort,
you can see, as you both use
the elevation maps that we've
been working on that involve
machine learning as well
as the models that we've made,
how much more accurate it is.
So if you're a person who lives
in this region, like earlier,
it would have said
it was flooding.
And then you would
have to evacuate--
or you would think that
you would need to evacuate.
But actually, when you look
at the more precise models,
you'll actually be safe.
So what we're hoping is--
through this work, you
can see that accuracy
has gone up to 79%.
And then when people
get the alerts,
they can have the
information that they need.
So as you can see on
the phone, what they'll
see moving into
this monsoon season
is, when you search
on Google, or when
you go into Google
Maps, and you're
in an affected region, it
will give you some more
information so that you
know how to keep yourself
and your family safe,
and whether or not you
should evacuate, and
when you get an alert
from Google public alerts.
PAIGE BAILEY: This is fantastic.
My academic background
is very focused
on quantitative hydrogeology
and geospatial reasoning.
And it's amazing to be able to
see the kind of accuracy uptick
that you get just by
using machine learning
with your elevation maps.
This is really, really cool.
CARLA BROMBERG: Thank you.
We're really excited.
And we hope we can save a lot
of lives ahead of this monsoon
season.
And we're hoping to also
expand this work across more
countries.
And for this, we're
partnering really
closely with the
Indian government,
and many others on the
ground, and first responders.
So hopefully we can
help get the word out
so that people can
evacuate to safety.
PAIGE BAILEY: Thank you so much
for telling me about this work.
And let's go and take a
look at the other demo
that we have from
AI for social good
that's very focused
on whale detection.
CARLA BROMBERG:
Yeah, absolutely.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hi, I'm
here with Julie Cattiau.
And she's here to tell me about
this really cool whale demo.
JULIE CATTIAU: Yeah,
nice to meet you.
So this is a demo that's related
to the bioacoustics project
at Google.
So we're a small team, part of
the AI for social good effort.
And so we've been
training machine
learning model to detect
the presence of animals
just by listening
to the audio sound.
EMILY FORTUNA: Very cool.
JULIE CATTIAU: And so
this project in particular
is a partnership with
NOAA, the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric
Administration, which is part
of the American government.
NOAA, in particular, has
a network of microphones.
These microphones have
been set up in 2005.
And they're in different
spots in the Pacific Ocean.
And so in the end, it
adds up to a lot of data.
And so NOAA-- the data set
that NOAA, in particular, was
interested in getting
our help to analyze
is close to 200,000
hours of audio.
So as you can imagine, nobody
can listen to the whole thing.
It's just way too long.
And that's where machine
learning can be very helpful.
Because with enough
examples of sounds,
machine learning can be
applied to recognizing
a particular species of animals
just by listening to the sound.
And actually, if you think about
animals that live in the ocean,
almost all of them produce
some sort of sounds, even fish,
which can be surprising.
Boats definitely
make a lot of noise.
They're not animals,
but they make noise.
Whales make sounds,
dolphins do too.
And so the question
for us was, can we
identify which species are
present in a audio data set
and classify them using
artificial intelligence?
So this demo here that you
can see represents three
months' worth of data from
that data set I was telling you
about.
And what you can
do is, if you slide
this tablet along the data, you
can see that this is actually
a spectrogram.
So it's a visual
representation of a sound.
This is frequency over time
for a particular sound.
And so NOAA provided some
examples of humpback whale
sounds.
And then we trained a model
to recognize those sounds
automatically.
And we used it on the
whole pile of data
that they had to tell
them where the whales were
and at which point in time.
When the color is light blue,
it means that our classifier
has detected a whale.
Would you like to listen
to the whale songs?
EMILY FORTUNA: Absolutely.
JULIE CATTIAU: OK.
[WHALE CALL]
EMILY FORTUNA: So I'm getting
lots of ocean sounds right now.
Oh, I hear the whale.
JULIE CATTIAU: You do?
Awesome.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's wonderful.
Well, thank you so much.
This is lovely.
JULIE CATTIAU: Yeah, thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: And It's--
I am-- it's great that you're
able to track whale migration
patterns.
JULIE CATTIAU: Yeah, thank
you for your interest.
[MUSIC PLAYING]